(crowd cheering)
(guitar riff)
- Like, I'm gonna totally
rip this whole plan
and just perform in this
on tour at some point.
This is so rock and roll.
- This is so beautiful
and rock and roll.
- It's like elegant
Fleetwood Mac.
It's very nice. I'm just saying.
- Well, I have to tell you,
I'm having an out of
body experience right now
because I was backstage,
and I saw you backstage
- Yeah.
- in a rust-colored dress.
And you were standing,
- Did you?
- like this with a
microphone to your mouth
and you had your hand like this.
(Kelly laughs)
And I said,
"Be quiet, she's praying."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
And I said, "This is
like something she does
before she goes on."
And I stood there, and I kind
of looked nodded over there.
This is what I saw, people.
(audience laughing)
- This is what- (laughing)
- It was her cutout.
(audience claps)
- So, for a minute-
- I was dying.
- For a minute, I was like,
"Am I gonna go with it
and pretend I was
backstage in another dress
earlier?"
- No.
- But yes, as soon as
you said I was praying.
This is what they put out
when they do the lighting and everything.
This is when they do the
stage at the Kellyokes.
- I began praying.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I was like, "Well this
is the way to do it."
I was like, "I need to breathe."
- She's very into it.
- I'm very- then I said
to your stage manager,
when you came on in the green, I said,
"But who is that then?,"
still thinking it was a live person.
- Oh my God!
- I said,
"Who is that over there?"
I'm a dingdong.
- No you're not.
It's me, and the first
time they introduced it
a long time ago, I don't even remember,
probably season one,
I looked and I was like, "Oh my God."
I thought they were playing footage back,
- Yeah.
- like, upstairs.
And I was like, "Oh, they're
playing- what song was this?"
- It's just the way it's back there.
- Yeah.
- You have to be
backstage in the darkness-
- And how they light it.
- They light it.
- Yeah.
- It was gonna talk to me
in a minute.
- But for a minute
this was gonna be hysterical
- Amen.
- 'cause I was just
gonna lie and go with it
that I was backstage.
- I know. (laughing)
- I was like-
- "I'm not gonna make Marsha stupid."
(Marsha laughs)
- Not gonna do it.
I was like, "Totally was backstage
in a dress like that."
- Yeah, I was.
Marsha needs a little help.
(both laughing)